si el departamento de salud de nueva
york acaba de anunciar que ha detectado
en las aguas residuales de la ciudad
signos del virus que causa la polio esto
sugiere que podría haber una posible
transmisión local comunitaria de este
virus el primer caso se detectó hace
algunas semanas en roland una comunidad
que se encuentra al norte de nueva york
allí el índice de vacunación por este
virus es bastante bajo comparado con el
resto del país de menos de un 60 por
ciento comparado con un 93% de índice de
vacunación en el resto de eeuu ese fue
el primer caso que se localizó de polio
en la última década aquí en eeuu hasta
allí se desplazó un equipo de
investigadores de los centros para el
control y prevención de enfermedades
dicen que están nerviosos que están
preocupados porque este virus está
infección podría salirse rápido de
nuestras manos han dicho por eso desde
el departamento de salud de la ciudad de
nueva york piden a todos los ciudadanos
que se vacunen inmediatamente si no lo
han hecho ya
el virus dicen que el virus de la polio
puede causar una parálisis irreversible
que podría provocar incluso la muerte